Paul Manafort in hot water again the
left ignores the situation on the border
and they go full alarmist about global
warming i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show already we have a lot to
get to today and i'm so happy that
you're here with us because it's a
joyous time of the year but the time
between Thanksgiving and Christmas and
New Year's it's just it's just great
everybody seems to have relaxed a little
bit except everyone in politics who's
losing their mind as per our usual
arrangement we'll get to all of that in
just one second first let's talk about
how you're sending your holiday package
of this year you're gonna go over to the
post office
you're gonna schlep all that stuff over
the post office you yes you gonna schlep
all that stuff why would you do that
why wouldn't you instead just stay home
and get all the wonderful services of
the post office direct from your house
that's where stamps calm comes in they
bring all the services of the u.s. post
office directly to your desktop you can
buy and print official US postage for
any letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer and printer and
then the mail carrier just picks it up
no trips to the post office required
couldn't be easier you print postage any
day any time stamps calm is always open
stamps calm not only saves you time it
saves you money stamps calm helps you
print the right amounts of postage every
single time never overpay again you just
print it right out onto the package or
onto a sticker or on a piece of paper
you tape it to the package and then the
mail carrier just takes it away I use
stamps calm here at the Daily wire
offices we use it at my home as well and
right now you can enjoy stamps calm
service with a special offer including a
four week trial plus postage and digital
scale awesome offer without any
long-term commitment just go to stamps
com click on the microphone at the top
of the home page type in promo code
Shapiro that stamps calm and for promo
code Shapiro for that special deal
stamps.com I go to the post office when
you get all its great services directly
from your desk stamps calm promo code
Shapiro all right so we begin today with
the latest update on Paul Manafort as
you recall Paul Manafort is the key
player in the Muller investigation and
there are a couple of pieces of news
that seem to have pretty significant
impact on the Muller investigation piece
of news number one came out earlier
yesterday courtesy of the Washington
Post Paul Manafort you'll remember was
the campaign manager for President Trump
for about four months in the middle of
the campaign from like March to June and
now according to prosecutors he has lied
to them again you remember he came to a
plea arrangement with them several
months ago
in which he was supposedly going to
testify on behalf of the Muller
investigation in a variety of manners
well now the Muller investigation seems
to have a problem here is what the
Washington Post reported prosecutors
with Special Counsel Robert Muller said
Monday that Paul Manafort breached his
plea agreement accusing president
Trump's former campaign chairman of
lying repeatedly to them in their
investigation into Russian interference
in the 2016 election Manta for tonight
doing so intentionally but both sides
agreed in a court filing that the US
District Judge Amy Berman Jackson of the
district should set sentencing
immediately the apparent collapse of
mana forts cooperation agreement is the
latest stunning turnaround in his case
exposing the longtime Republican
consultant to at least a decade behind
bars after he pled guilty in September
to charges of cheating
the IRS violating foreign lobbying laws
in attempting to obstruct justice as
well as well as wearing suits made out
of like ostrich that was like an actual
thing he wasn't charged over that but he
was wearing a jacket made of ostrich
which let's be frank if you are going to
be an international criminal and you
don't have a suit made of ostrich I
don't know what you've been doing all
your life the filing also indicated that
Muller's team may have lost it's
potentially most valuable witness in
Manta for a top campaign official
present at discussions at the heart of
the special counsels mission to
determine if any Americans conspired
with Russia's efforts to sway the u.s.
election so this posed a serious problem
for Robert Muller if your key witness is
Paul Manafort and you just accused your
key witness of lying to you and then you
revoked his plea arrangement then that
would seem to kind of crush your case if
this is the guy on whose credibility
lies the entire Muller investigation
itself and the key elements of the
Malheur investigation well this is a
pretty big problem for you if you've
been building a case against against
Michael Corleone and it turns out that
your key witness you now have to
withdraw because he's been lying to you
it's gonna be hard to convict Michael
Corleone unless as it turns out there is
a second story so here is the second
story this one not so good for team
Trump so according to the Guardian which
has been the the leaked source for a lot
of got a Muller investigation related
stuff that is damaging to the Trump
administration here is what the Guardian
reports and this is a bombshell Donald
Trump's former campaign manager Paul
Manafort held secret talks with Hewlett
with Julian Assange inside the
Ecuadorian Embassy in London and visited
the time he joined the Trump campaign
The Guardian has been told now why is
this important well because Julian
Assange is a WikiLeaks guy WikiLeaks is
a Russian front group Russia was hacking
Hillary Clinton's email and hacking the
DNC and then taking all of that email
and dumping it to WikiLeaks who was
dumping it in public and the accusation
all along has been that the Trump
campaign was coordinating in the release
of the WikiLeaks of the WikiLeaks emails
in the WikiLeaks documents in order to
sink Hillary Clinton's campaign so until
now there was no open collaboration or
any collaboration of any sort really
between the Trump campaign and WikiLeaks
the closest connection was Roger stone
who was under investigation by the
Muller investigation and that is because
Roger stone had been sort of bragging to
various folks that he was talking with
WikiLeaks he maintains that WikiLeaks
did not advance him any information
before it was publicly released CNN had
reported about a year ago wrongly that
Donald Trump jr. had been coordinating
with WikiLeaks they had no evidence of
that well now maybe here's the bombshell
that the Democrats and the media I've
been looking for sources have said the
palm Ana fort went to see who Leanne
Assange in 2013 2015 and in spring 2016
during the period when he was made a key
figure in Trump's push for the White
House it is unclear why manna fort would
have wanted to see Assange and what was
discussed but the last apparent meeting
is likely to come under scrutiny and
could interest robert muller the special
prosecutor who is investigating alleged
collusion between the Trump campaign and
Russia a well-placed source and here's
where things start to get dicey a
well-placed source has told the Guardian
the manna fort went to see a song around
March 2016 we don't know who the
well-placed source is we don't know what
that means
we don't know whether the source is
coming from the Russian camp from the
Assange camp from the Muller camp we do
not know months later WikiLeaks released
a stash of democratic emails stolen by
Russian intelligence officers we also
don't know by the way about the timing
the reason we don't know about the
timing is because he didn't only see
Assange once even according to these
sources Assange was met by manna for in
2013 when he was working with the
government of Ukraine which was then
sort of a puppet government for the
Russians apparently 2015 and in spring
2016 so he visited three times two of
those times he was not in the pay of the
Trump campaign
so is it possible that he was still
visiting with his house about Russia
related stuff that was not campaign
related that is possible as well
man afford two knives involvement in the
hack he says the claim is 100% false his
lawyers have declined to answer the
Guardians questions about the visits in
a series of tweets WikiLeaks had a
Songshan man afford had not met Assange
describes the story as a hoax well just
cuz Assange says something doesn't mean
that it's an actual thing right it is
not clear that Assange is a truth teller
in fact it's pretty clear that he's not
man affort was jailed this year and was
thought to have become a star cooperator
in the Muller enquiry on Monday Muller
said mana Ford had repeatedly lied to
the FBI despite agreeing to cooperate
two months ago in a plea deal according
to a court document man affort had
committed crimes and lies on a variety
of subject matters so this was always
the real question about Story number one
that we discussed earlier Manta for
lying to Muller
why would Muller go out of his way to
revoke a plea arrangement that cast his
star witness in a credibility problem
that created a credibility problem for
his star witness well the answer could
be that maybe the credibility problem
for his star witness is actually not a
problem for the Muller investigation if
it turns out that he's basically traded
Muller traded mana for its credibility
for evidence of mana for actively
colluding with the Russian so he doesn't
need man afford anymore is the idea now
he no longer needs mana for its
testimony instead he's got Assange
there's a rumour that has been going
around has been reported upon that
Assange is going to be indicted by the
US government on some matter it is not
clear what that matter is he's not
emerging from the Ecuadorian Embassy any
time soon to tell us exactly but all of
this makes things a lot easier for Team
Trump then things were yesterday at this
time now does this mean anything is
going materialize no you still have to
connect all the dots let's say an Manta
format with Assange so we have several
questions one did Manta for me with
Assange guardian says yes we don't know
to what exactly did they meet about the
Guardian suggests that it was about the
campaign but again man afforded met with
Assange several times before not clear
that it was about to campaign 3 did
Trump know that his own guy was meeting
with Assange that is not clear either
for did mana for actively collaborate
with Assange in the release of the
WikiLeaks emails especially since most
of the key WikiLeaks emails came out
long after man
four left the campaign so there there's
still a bunch of questions here in the
media are jumping to the conclusion that
all the dots have now been connected and
therefore Trump is guilty of something
but Trump had to know stuff people in
this campaign had to know stuff in order
for anything to be brought against Trump
himself apparently according to the
Guardian Manta Ford's 2016 visit to
Assange lasted about 40 minutes one
source said adding the American was
casually dressed when he exited the
embassy wearing sandy colored chinos a
cardigan and a light-colored shirt which
is underdressed for Paul Manafort
visitors normally register with embassy
security guards and show their passports
sources in Ecuador however say Manta
fort was not logs which is really weird
why exactly would mana fort not be
logged by the Ecuadorian embassy embassy
staff were aware only later of the
potential significance of Manta forts
visit and his political role with Trump
it is understood so again we still have
a lot of questions that have to be
answered about all of this according to
sources Manta forts acquaintance with
Asajj goes back at least five years to
late 2012 or 2013 when the American was
working in Ukraine and advising its
Moscow friendly President Viktor
Yanukovych why manna for might have
sought out Assange in 2013 is unclear so
a lot of this is not clear at this point
but that's not going to stop people from
from immediately connecting all the dots
so we will see how all of this plays out
in real time meanwhile the chaos on the
border continues to bewilder folks on
the left and they're trying to now spin
the story that President Trump is cruel
and inhumane to the people on the border
in a way that no one has been
historically this seems unlikely
and when I say unlikely I mean it seems
untrue because as it turns out using
tear gas against people who are
attempting to break through the border
has been an extraordinarily common
occurrence it happened during Obama's
presidency many many many times
according to the Washington Times the
same tear gas agent the Trump
administration is taking heat for
deploying against a border mob this
weekend is actually used fairly
frequently including more than once a
month during the later years of
President Barack Obama's administration
according to homeland security data US
Customs and Border Protection has used
two chlorobenzene
mal melanin nitro or CS since 2010 and
deployed it 26 times in fiscal year 2012
and 27 times in 2013 the use dropped
after that but was still deployed three
times in 2016
authorities also use another agent
pepper spray frequently including a
decade high record of 151 times in 2013
also under President Obama so as usual
when it comes to the unprecedented
nature of president Trump's activity
there's precedent as it turns out the
Obama administration did this kind of
stuff all the time but that didn't stop
Democrats from claiming that Trump had
done something wild and unprecedented
here sheer panic about the border sheer
panic it's so funny all the folks on the
Left who accused Republicans of climate
change denial ISM which we'll get to in
just a few minutes all those folks are
engaged in boards and Iowa's amount of
routine basis and we're supposed to
ignore it we'll get to that in just one
second but first let's talk about your
impending death so we all know that
you're going to plotz sometime in the
future I'm not gonna say that it's
tomorrow no god forbid
hopefully it'll be a hundred and twenty
years from now if you're born today in
Jewish law you can only live 120 years
that's not Jewish law it's what a Jewish
tradition is 120 years you maxed out
your credit cards done times up see you
later friends but let's say you haven't
reach 120 yet but you gotta prepare for
that eventuality this is why you need
policy genius because having life
insurance is actually a really good
feeling you want to make sure that if
you plotz your family is not left for
Klimt you want to make sure that your
family is grieved over your passing sure
but not poor because they can't afford
your fancy casket it's nice to know that
if anything were to happen to me we
wouldn't need a GoFundMe to stay afloat
so I have life insurance well if you're
if you are a responsible human then you
should be doing it the same thing policy
genius is the easy way to get life
insurance online in just two minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
to find the best policy for you when you
compare quotes you say bunny it is
indeed that simple competitive
capitalistic pricing that's what policy
genius is all about they've helped over
4 million people shop for insurance so
if you've been avoiding getting life
insurance because it's difficult or
confusing give policy genius a trial or
policy genius com get the quotes apply
in minutes you can do the whole thing on
your phone right now
policy genius it's the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance go check
it out right now so meanwhile meanwhile
the Democrats continue to claim that
president Trump's use of tear gas on the
border his administration's use of tear
gas is just the worst thing ever and
they're making up stories now and
they're trying to come up with a reason
why it's just terrible what happened on
the border but the reason can't be
people trying to storm the border and
throw rocks at border agents that can't
be it's not those people
it's Trump's fault always remember it is
Trump's fault orange man bad as they say
on the interwebs so president Trump was
asked about this and in typical trumpian
fashion he said the tear gas is
extremely safe and then he talked about
a lighter version of tear gas that
doesn't exist so here is the President
of the United States first of all the
tear gas is a very minor form of the
tear gas itself it's very safe the ones
that were suffering through a certain
extent were the people that were putting
it out there but it's very safe but you
really say why is a parent running up
into an area where they know the tear
gas is forming and it's going to be
formed and they're running up with a
child and in some cases you know they're
not the parents these are people they
call them grabbers they grab a child
because they think they're gonna have a
certain they're gonna have a certain
status by having a child you know you
have certain advantages in terms of our
crazy laws that frankly Congress should
be changing you know if you change the
laws you wouldn't be having this problem
and I think the funding of the wall
right now is never look better okay so I
think a lot of what President Trump has
to say here is is basically correct
although I don't know about a lighter
form of tear gas I've never heard of
such a thing and I don't know that they
actually call people grabbers I've never
heard that one before either maybe I'm
mistaken
whenever President Trump talks about
grabbing I think of something else in
any case president Trump is not wrong on
the policy merits here when people throw
rocks at you then you are allowed to
defend yourself and you are defending
yourself not by shooting people not by
be even using rubber bullets but instead
by using tear gas it Border Patrol chief
was asked about all of this on CNN this
is Kevin michaleen Macaulay Ninh who is
the Commissioner of US Customs and
Border Protection and Chris Cuomo who's
a block of wood and Chris Cuomo asked
Kevin McHale inan about the use of tear
gassing Kevin Mack Elena's like dude
because people throw rocks at us what do
you want from me unfortunately the
migrants pushed through them overwhelmed
them went around them and down through
the Tijuana River Channel and then tried
to enter the US unlawfully through the
southbound lanes of the port of entry we
responded and prevented that access at
the border line they then went back
around San Ysidro and then started to
look for a weak spot
in the international border fence on the
east side of San Ysidro at several
points they tried to tear down parts of
the wall and make a large group entry
and it was in those engagements where
people started throwing rocks assaulting
our agents we had four agents hit with
rocks how thankfully they were wearing
protective gear we don't have any
serious injuries but they did have to
respond to resolve those assaultive
engagements as safely as possible with
less lethal pepper ball spray as well as
CS gas okay so uh yes tear gas Chris
Cuomo
yes that's what tear gas is block of
wood human so in any case this obviously
is not a misuse of resources this
obviously is what has to be done to
quell the border situation but this does
not stop Democrats from issuing a bunch
of idiotic statements about the
situations where I mean fully idiotic
again folks on the left wanna talk about
climate change denial ISM we'll get to
that issue because there's a climate
report the left is going crazy over but
when we were talking about denialism on
an issue words and aisle ISM is a form
of denial ISM denying that there is a
problem when people rush the border
throw rocks at agents and try to break
through the southbound lanes at the port
of entry I don't understand why you
would do that other than you have a
political agenda so here's what the
Democrats had to say about this Joaquin
Castro who's a representative in Texas
who for some odd reason thinks he should
run for president he he told Chris Hayes
who is not in fact Rachel Maddow on
MSNBC he told he told every by the way
that that's not a rip on what these
people look like it's just there's one
pair of glasses at MSNBC it's a black
frame pair of glasses like black rimmed
glasses and every single person puts
them on and looks the same on MSNBC this
is the rule on MSNBC you actually can't
sit behind the anchors desk unless you
wear the same pair of glasses
in any case Joaquin Castro talking to
Chris Hayes and Joaquin Castro says all
this stuff that's happening to border
it's Trump's fault why well explain it
walking well like a lot of Americans I
was horrified to see women and children
these are folk babies and diapers
barefoot being gassed and I think
Americans were horrified at the idea of
agents of the United States government
making a decision to use tear gas on
kids that are 2 or 3 years old and as
you mentioned this was a self-created
chaotic situation by the president he
has used migrants from day one even
before he became president during the
campaign as the number one political
boogeyman for him he has weaponized
resentment and fear of migrants
basically to his political benefit and
that's why you see him do a lot of
things that he does with respect to
migration and immigration okay I love
this on MSNBC the Chiron's has a
spectacle of cruelty a spectacle of
cruelty and then at Joaquin Castro
saying they're firing teargas at babies
well no they're firing tear gas at
people who are throwing rocks at them
and trying to cross the border illegally
and if those people are carrying babies
that seems to me the fault of the people
who carry babies into what seems to be a
quasi war zone right I mean if you if I
would have a two and a half year old
child I would not bring my two and a
half year old child to a border to try
and break through illegally knowing that
people on the other side we're going to
fire tear gas which has again happened
dozens and dozens and dozens of times
per year including under President Obama
this is idiocy my favorite idiotic
comment of the day on the border
situation came courtesy of Andrea
Mitchell again of MSNBC this is pretty
spectacular stuff say nothing of the
diamond amazing of all of this by
calling them a caravan and and
describing them based on no observable
facts is unknown Middle Easterners
without any evidence of that
five hundred murderers and in the midst
et cetera yeah okay this is so
unbelievably stupid so here is why this
is so stupid all you have to do it's
amazing people don't know how to use
Google I I'm serious people on the Left
I don't know in the media like Google in
in the words of our friend Chang agar
google it it's really not difficult to
actually Google things okay so for
example watch as I google this see my
fingers here my fingers are currently
typing migrant caravan okay migrant
Caravan and now I'm going to use the
tools here on Google and I'm going to
change the date range to one one 2014
and let's see if before that anyone had
ever used the language of a migrant
Caravan why look the first result from
The Daily Beast the Department of
Homeland Security is reportedly tracking
a new migrant caravan that is set to
leave El Salvador next week 2011 how
about this one from June 13 2013 from
8:50 WFT
the migrant caravan reformed after
Mexican authorities denied entry to
large groups on this bridge at the
border how about this one from NBC
Philadelphia February 1st 2001 large
crowds on both sides of the border near
San Ysidro and Tijuana marched in
support of the migrant caravan why it
seems that the language of migrant this
one's from the New York Times 2006 new
migrant caravans trek north Wow it's
almost as though President Trump did not
actually come up with the term migrant
caravan and you're stupid if you think
he did almost as though that is the case
and that you should have used your
Google skills if you have them okay that
I have to admit that one is pretty bad
wait until you hear Bernie Sanders and
Maxine Waters take on this thing you
want to know why people are alienated by
the left when it comes to national
security this would be the reason why
people are alienated by the left when it
comes to national security
now speaking of national security and
personal security when the founders
crafted the Constitution the first thing
they did was to make sacred the rights
of the individual to share your ideas
and then the second thing they did was
make sure you could protect those rights
with a firearm which is why Bravo
company manufacturing exists it was
started in a garage by marine vet more
than two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product and meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they are a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer
manufacturer of life-saving equipment
they assume that every rifle leaving
their shop will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen law enforcement officer or a
soldier overseas each components of a
BCM rifle is hand assembled and tested
by Americans to a life-saving standard
to learn more about bravo company
manufacturing all you have to do is head
on over to bravo company MFG comm where
you can discover more about their
products special offers upcoming news
they feel a moral responsibilities
Americans provide tools that are going
to work for you and will not fail in the
case of an emergency situation and they
work with leading instructors of
marksmanship from the top levels of
America's Special Ops who can teach the
skills necessary to defend yourself
your family or others that's Bravo
Company MFG comm again go check them out
at youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA
to see the people behind the company and
to see all the products that make really
cool stuff Bravo Company MFG comm we
could not be prouder to partner with
Bravo Company MFG comm
right so the dumbest statements of the
day with regard to the border caravan
were reserved for Bernie Sanders and
Maxine Waters yes even stupider than
Andrea Mitchell saying that President
Trump using the word caravan is
demonizing immigrants well I don't know
it's announcer running through a gun
battle on the dumbest comet Allison
camera out ahead one on CNN Bernie
Sanders have won and Maxine Waters had
won
so let's spin the wheel of dumb here we
go okay now let's start with Ellison
camerado so Allison Cammarata made the
suggestion on CNN that because people
storm the border this is why we don't
need a wall see if you can follow that
logic hey that's that makes sense
because someone broke into your house
you don't need a front door obviously
and it would've broken if you even
didn't have a front door so why you
haven't front what's the point of the
front door you idiot
why are you doing that yeah you're the
kind of person where somebody broke in
your house and you got four more locks
on your door didn't you have a lock on
your door in the first place or four
more locks going to do if this does not
seem to follow that's because it's dumb
so here's Allison camerado on CNN saying
something that is not particularly
intelligent as unfortunate as this
incident is I'm not sure that it proves
that we need a border wall in fact it's
the opposite the border worked border
security here worked so however many
people rushed the border 39 were
arrested they are going to be deported
no one breached the border so shutting
down the border worked and it also
proves that we don't need a board I
think a border wall because the migrants
made an actor went out of their way to
go to the Tijuana entrance because the
rest of the border was considered too
hazardous too dangerous to cross
so they went an extra hundreds of miles
to the port of entry of Tijuana because
they considered that the easiest so in
other words the system is actually
working mmm interesting interesting take
Allison cammarata so we don't need a
border wall because people tried to
break through the border wall and went
to Tijuana because it was easier well
actually no they went to Tijuana because
they wanted the publicity and a huge
number of people do cross the unguarded
portions of the us-mexico border and as
you may have noticed scaling the wall
was significantly less successful than
them trying to
break through just the southern lanes of
traffic so walls tend to make people go
around the walls that's why they're
there okay so that was that was dumb
take number one don't take number two
Bernie Sanders he has a take a very
interesting take and his take is that
President Trump only wants to enforce
the border because of fascism now in the
nature of this president yeah it's okay
we can plan who I think has strong
authoritarian tendencies who seems a lot
of people like mr. Putin and the crown
prince of Saudi Arabia and the leader of
North Korea I worry very much about for
the first time using the military in
that way or in this country so I think
that is a very legitimate concern okay
so he's worried that if we send troops
to our border to defend our border
that's fascism because it's a crackdown
on people who are not citizens trying to
get into the country as opposed to
countries that Bernie Sanders has been
fond of in the past like Venezuela and
Cuba and the USSR those were not fascist
cuz there they had walls to keep people
in but that wasn't fascist so Bernie
Sanders doing his best to say a dumb
thing also Maxine Waters who is going to
be the head of the House Financial
Services Committee maybe which is just
horrifying and every wife last time she
was related to last time she was deeply
involved in the House Financial Services
Committee she proceeded to attempt to
drive cash to her husband's Bank here is
Maxine Waters a woman who knows a lot
about failure to abide by the law both
herself and with regard to the LA riots
which she called an LA uprising
explaining that the border chaos is a
political ploy by Trump because somehow
Trump this is what he does I mean
Trump's a magical magical man president
Trump went down to that border and what
he did is he just he's very stealthy
this is one thing we know about
President Trump the dude doesn't draw
any attention I mean he is just he's a
master of disguise
president Trump took off his hair and he
put on a beard and Groucho Marx glasses
and then he strode into the middle of
the my grand caravan he said guys I need
you to do something for me please try to
break through the border por favor
that's exactly how it went here's Maxine
Waters explaining how that was
I am very saddened to see this situation
with desperate people and all of this
being at the political ploy of the
President of the United States of
America he made this the central part of
his platform that he was going to do
something about these migrants who are
coming here
he called them killers and rapists and
he certainly did stoke a lot of fear
about these migrants who are trying to
get in and so he promised the American
people that he was going to make Mexico
paper at all that we would not have to
pay a dime boy and now we have this
chaos that's what he wants Oh as opposed
to as opposed to when there was chaos on
the border when Obama was president
which I recall and you recall and
everybody recalls so running gun battle
for dumbest thing to be said about the
border situation just wonderful so my
favorite part of all of this is that
awkward time at MSNBC reporter actually
revealed that the caravan was not full
of suffering women and children that was
a bunch of young men who are looking for
economic opportunity that's when all
this got real awkward she had MSNBC and
CNN filled to the brim with commentators
and Congress people saying this is all
Trump's fault and then it got real
awkward cuz a reporter at MSNBC down
there was like um guys
Trump's kind of not wrong about all this
stuff the truth is the majority of the
people that are part of this Caravan
especially outside if we can make our
way all the way over there we'll show
you the majority of them are men so when
this becomes a polarized political issue
in the United States you have people on
one side that point and say there are
women and children here and that is true
and then there are others who point and
say these are men that are trying to
cross the border and that's true too
from what we've seen the majority are
actually men okay oops
whoops II do yeah he said the unsayable
but again when it comes to the border
it's the Democrats who are denialists
now in a second we're going to talk
about climate change denial ISM because
this is the new charge the left has been
throwing at everybody on the right the
idea is that you are a climate change
denier if you disagree with their
prospective solutions which involve
massive damage to the world economy and
particularly the United States economy
in service to
something right is it is not clear by
any stretch of the imagination even from
the proponents of the measures that are
now being promoted by a lot of these
folks that these measures will actually
succeed in curbing global warming in any
serious way we're going to talk about
the new study that was released by the
federal government and that Trump has
downplayed and that the media are
playing up in just one second plus I
need to talk to you about a new poll of
Western Europeans about anti-semitism
because while we in the West fulminate
over racism while we fulminate over
white supremacism while we fulminate
over all the terrible things in the
United States we sort of tend to ignore
the much broader problems with bigotry
so long as they don't fit the
intersectional narrative we'll get to
that in just one second first I got to
talk to you about this fantastic new
podcast it is just it's just great I
love history I mean I really love
history and there's a brand new podcast
called assassinations by the podcast
network it digs deep to find
little-known facts about assassins their
assassination attempts and the effect
these had on history I have a little bit
of an obsession about reading about
these sorts of things I'm very into the
topic of who V assassins were how this
affected Future History I've heard a
bunch of counter narratives and council
histories what would have happened if
you have K weren't assassinated for
example what would happened if Lincoln
hadn't been assassinated well the new
podcast assassinations takes on a lot of
these issues assassination takes a deep
dive into the life of some of the
world's most infamous assassins to
discover what motivated them to take
such drastic measures the host examined
the assassinations through the lens
about the target and the assassin asking
did the assassin ultimately achieve his
underlying objective and if so how
exactly did that change the world look
for upcoming episodes on Abraham Lincoln
and grigori rasputin who you'll recall
was the supposed whisperer to the to the
Russian royal family just before the
Russian Revolution check out the
three-part episode on John F Kennedy
right now new episodes come every Monday
search and subscribe to assassinations
wherever you listen to podcasts again
that's a ssa ssi and a TI ons
assassinations or visit podcast.com
slash assassinations to start listening
now that's power cast PARC a st.com
slash assassinations to listen right now
go check it out it is really a great
listen okay well I have a lot to get to
I want to talk to you about this climate
change report that people are going
crazy over in just one second but you're
gonna have to go over to Daley wire calm
and subscribe for $9.99 a month you can
subscribe to daily wire yes I mean you
you're capable
of doing this thing and when you you get
the rest of my show live you get the
rest of Clavin show live you get the
rest of Noel's show live you get early
episodes of another Kingdom
Andrew Clavin is great book read by the
mediocre Michael Knowles with with art
by our fantastic art team there's only
one elements I think is a little bit
short in that particular math but you
can check it all out and make your own
judgment when you get the normal
subscription or at the annual which is
even better why is it better you asked
well number one it's cheaper is
ninety-nine dollars a year not $9.99
second you get this the very greatest in
beverage vessels now I'm not gonna say
but this the left is here's hot or cold
tumbler will cure all your ills I'm not
going to pretend that this thing can
protect you from all illness all I will
tell you is that some plague has hit my
entire family it hit two of my sisters
it hit it hit my niece two of my sisters
it hit my wife it has not hit me why why
you ask has it not hit me well the
answer I'm not gonna say that it's
because I drink from the leftist cheers
hot or cold tumblr every day which
fortifies me against the vicissitudes of
life all I can say is that correlation
may equal causation probably not but but
a good that's all I'm saying okay go
check it out right now also subscribe
over at iTunes or YouTube when you do
make sure you leave us a review on
iTunes it helps with the ranking and you
get access to our Sunday specials you
have a bunch of awesome pre-christmas
sunday specials that are coming out in
which a bunch of people are gonna try
and convert me it's gonna be really
fantastic but really it's it's there's
all sorts of really good stuff so go
check it out right now we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so ah the left is completely focused on
denying what's happening at the border
and blaming Trump for stuff that's been
going on for you know our entire life
now they are also claiming that
everybody on the right is a climate
change denier who a denier now I hate
the language that is used with regard to
climate change deniers because obviously
it's supposed to be reminiscent of
Holocaust denial wasn't like you're
denying an established fact that's
millions of people died in the Holocaust
you're just like those people
you're just the same grave consequences
okay we're gonna need to be clear about
what you mean by denial of climate
change are we denying the climate
changes at all no one denies the climate
changes at all are we denying that the
world has gotten on average warmer over
time over the last hundred and fifty
years or so there are a few people deny
that are we denying that man-made
emissions have something to do with that
very few people deny that are we denying
that the majority of those changes are
coming because of man-related activities
a minority would probably a strong
minority might deny that but I would say
strong majority probably supports that
even among people who happen to be on
the right but you can acknowledge all
those things and then if you say but I
don't want a massive carbon tax in order
to I think this is a crisis
necessitating the death of the world
economy then it's like Oh your denier
because what I'm really denying what I'm
really denying is that your solution is
the proper solution folks on the Left I
don't think that your solution is the
right solution in fact I think that you
are alarmist I think that you are
creating alarm around a problem that is
not in fact as extraordinarily dire as
you make it out to be rather cost to
global warming sure are those cost being
wildly exaggerated for political
purposes by folks on the left you bet
your ass they are so there's a new study
out and this new study suggests millions
will die thanks to climate change and
this leads all the people in the
Democratic caucus to tweet out you don't
care if millions of people die okay let
me just tell you you already said we're
gonna die cos in net neutrality the
other said the tax cuts we're gonna kill
us
you already said that revoking parts of
Obamacare I was gonna kill millions and
we're already dead like three times over
how many times we needed that Cavanaugh
was gonna get like we're all gonna die
so where I've died like four times am i
cat here like I can't actually die that
many times it turns out and now they're
citing this new federal study that has
come out that supposedly
shows that we are all going to die why
well because there's a
brand new report from the CDC and it
confirms that climate change is going to
kill thousands of people thousands of
humans will die okay so well how do we
know that lots of people are going to
die let me give you the ridiculous math
behind some of these things so they say
for example that the consensus is that
over the next century the water level
could rise not well could all the
modeling so far have been wrong that it
could rise by five feet in certain areas
of the United States like three feet in
Los Angeles the general water levels
could rise well number one the water
level rises that have been forecast so
far have not actually been accurate and
number two if that happens over the
course of a century you think people
might move their houses you think maybe
people might move inland you know like
they have over the course of time many
people had adapt to their climate
because human beings are adaptable
creatures
I'm always bewildered by this idea that
humans can't move I mean that's how do
you think people got to America how do
you think people got to different parts
of the globe in any case this is my
favorite part the people on the Left are
taking the most extraordinary claims of
this of this study and then they are
claiming that this is evidence that the
National Climate Assessment means that
we're all going to die so CNN put out
the statistic you've seen in all the
headlines on the front page of the New
York Times there is a possibility of a
10% loss in GDP due to climate change by
2100 ooh
10% loss in GDP in climate change by
2100 now that 10% loss does not actually
envision a 10% loss from our current
global GDP it is a 10% lower GDP than
would otherwise be the case without
global warming in a hundred years and
100 years our GDP is gonna be pretty
frickin amazing right just by global
trends our GDP is going to be
extraordinary but here's what's even
weirder it turns out that the 10% GDP
number is not consistent with the
physical science part of the report it
is a political conclusion buried in
chapter 29 of the report according to
Roger Pelkey who is author of the edge
the honest broker and the climate fix so
here is what he says he says that it is
it represents a temperature change two
times the already implausible RCP 8.5
scenario so all of these climate change
reports rely on a variety of scenarios
what they say is we don't know where
this is going and so they present a
bunch of scenarios they present the
served scenario which basically has
mirrored the lowest scenario thus far
and then they present the the lower
scenario which is RCP 4.5 and the higher
scenario which is our CP 8.5 but the RCP
8.5 is associated with only a four
degree celsius temperature change over
the course of the next century so how
exactly are they coming to this 10%
figure they are doubling that figure
they're doubling it okay there they're
coming up with a number that is double
what their own report says okay it's
it's it's really astonishing
I mean astonishing stuff so according to
pinky if the experts are gonna demand
they be trusted their numbers should add
up right here they don't one way to
ensure robust assessments is to invite
critical voices rather than exclude them
this error was easily preventable but
that that idea that 10% is gonna be
knocked off the GDP is just not true
it's not even true according to the
report itself it was promoted by people
but again this was a complete miss read
of the scientific part of the report
that's not the only mystery they say
thousands will die why because they say
that thanks to climate change
how do they know that you're going to
kill yourself because it's hot outside
according to Robinson mayor over at the
Atlantic unusually hot days have
profound effects on mental health and
human physiology suicide is one of the
least understood phenomena and social
science it's very difficult to link
social forces to suicide it's difficult
to link bullying to suicide it's
difficult to link poverty to suicide
it's difficult to link race to suicide
it is very difficult to find out where
to us but this report says the 26,000
more people will kill themselves by 2050
because it's hot outside forgive me if I
go no not so much now there's a
difference between acknowledging the
reality of climate change and trying to
figure out what are the best measures
and when with those measures kick in and
denying climate change itself and I
think the simple-minded version here is
to say climate change isn't happening or
it's not man caused I'm not suggesting
any of that so I am NOT in fact a
climate denier but if you're going to
make claims those claims should be
backed by science and the measures that
you are projecting out should have some
bearing on what exactly you are seeking
to prevent
I'll get to all that in just one second
but first let me show so let me start by
showing you what President Trump had to
say here's what President Trump had to
say about the climate change report
released by his own scientists again
these scientists are drawing political
conclusions the same thing happened with
the IPCC report the intern at the
International Panel on social science
all that happened on climate change all
of that happened months ago and we did
we went through that report like in full
on the show then they're doing the same
thing now and Trump's like listen a lot
of this stuff is political and again
he's not wrong you're gonna have to have
China and Japan and all of Asia and all
of these other countries you know
address addresses our country right now
we're at the cleanest we've ever been
and that's very important to me but if
we're clean but every other place on
earth is dirty that's not so good so I
want clean air I want clean water very
important ok well he's not saying
anything wrong here and he is correct
that if the United States were to cut
emissions which we have been we were the
single largest producers of emissions
last year if we were to cut emissions by
ourselves you know what happened to
global warming pretty much nothing
because China is still the leading
emitter on planet earth India is a
leading emitter Russia is a leading
emitter there are lots of developing
countries that are leading emitters
China by the way I love that everybody
like well China signed on to the Paris
Accords and the United States didn't the
United States reduced its emissions last
year you know what China did they
increased their emissions last year
they've been increasing their emissions
every year they are planning to increase
their emissions all the way up till 2030
for another 12 years minimum yeah but
this doesn't stop Anderson Cooper from
CNN saying you know maybe president trim
I love the least sneering here maybe
president Trump should check out chime
at climate change kids because he's like
a child he doesn't understand climate
change the President of the United
States seems to be honestly believing
that global warming means it never gets
cold anywhere nASA has a good
explanation of the difference between
weather and climate on its website its
website for children so we're just
suggesting mr. president if you don't
want to believe science or the sixteen
hundred page report your team tried to
slip past the American public on Friday
maybe just start with climate kids dot
nasa.gov hey do you think that Anderson
Cooper read that sixteen hundred page
report do you think the Nandor Singh
Cooper holds by his rule of not
reporting weather as climate because it
seems like every time there's a
hurricane we hear from the left that
this is a this is a climate change issue
as opposed to you know a weather event
every time it is extraordinarily hot in
California like ooh climate change right
so the the the the media have been
complicit in the conflation of weather
and climate weather is a trend or
pattern over time climate I mean that is
that is climate weather is individual
climate events right it's an individual
event it's hot outside today this is not
evidence of a trend over time it's a
data point in any case the the left is
in the habit of exaggerating these
reports and picking out the most the
most alarmist headlines which then are
never met what's fascinating about this
is if folks on the Left really wanted us
to take climate change seriously it
would be moderate in their assessments
they would say okay here's the moderate
case and then here's what we should do
to prevent the moderate case from
happening instead they picked the most
wild outlying alarmist predictions like
10 percent loss of GDP by 2100 and like
that that's what's gonna happen
heyo thirty thousand people are gonna
commit suicide cuz it's hot outside and
this is where they go they pick the most
alarmist prediction and then when it
doesn't materialize and the right goes
hey you know you guys been doing this
crap for twenty years
yeah Al Gore claimed that all the polar
icecaps were gonna be gone like five
years ago they're not gone and then the
left's like well that's because you
don't take this stuff seriously how
about if you just told us what your
moderate prediction was that you can
fulfill and then I could take seriously
the rest of your predictions again the
IPCC has to consider has consistently
revised downward its estimates of
impending doom in an AR five report in
2014 according to that report the level
of climate change observed was going to
be higher than it was in their recent
IPCC report and also we have to actually
determine how much damage is going to be
done as I mentioned on the show before
there's a guy named William Nordhaus at
Yale the political left celebrated him
because he won the Nobel Prize in
Economics this year hey it was supposed
to be a slap in the face to the Trump
administration but Nord House's work
suggests that the IPCC alarmism is just
wrong he himself argues the optimal
trajectory for climate when entered with
a 3.5 degree Celsius increase in Celsius
increase in degrees in global
temperature by 20
100 not 1.5 degrees or even two degrees
he says that the international target
for climate change with a limit of two
degrees Celsius is infeasible he says a
target of 2.5 2.5 degrees Celsius is
technically feasible but would require
extreme and virtually universal global
policy measures in the near future he
said if we tried to hold to 2.5 degrees
Celsius it could have hurt 91 trillion
dollars of damage but would cost 134
trillion dollars in economic damage when
the left says well if we just take a few
minor economic fixes here that'll think
nope nope it won't it won't if they're
most alarmist predictions are true but
they're really calling for is a complete
breakdown of the world economy so forget
about a 10% reduction in GDP by 2100 we
were talking about a 50% reduction in
GDP like now right that's what they're
actually talking about if they believe
their own worst-case assessments all
this isn't again the alarmism is what's
killing the case for climate change and
it's why people don't believe the worst
because the worst has not materialized
speaking of which we keep hearing about
carbon taxes from the left right well
what we really need here is carbon taxes
carbon taxes are definitely going to fix
everything well Oren cast talked about
climate taxes Oren cast Manhattan
Institute we've had him as a guest on
the program he talked about climate -
about carbon taxes back in 2015 in
national affairs here's what he wrote in
efficient tax on carbon emissions would
require a valid estimate for the cost
such emissions imposed on society but
any estimate of the social cost of
carbon which is the marginal cost of an
additional ton of co2 involves what
economists call an integrated assessment
model but stats assumptions upon
assumptions upon assumptions the results
of such modeling is not much better than
a guess calling these models close to
useless says MIT economist Robert Penn
deck is generous to model a relationship
between carbon emissions and costs IMS
this would be the integrated assessment
models must first assume a climate
sensitivity that is how quickly the
climate will respond to a doubling of
co2 in the atmosphere
the IPCC offers a range of assumptions
from one point five to four point five
degrees Celsius and that range has
actually grown wider in recent years so
in order for us to assess the cost we
have to determine how sensitive is the
climate we have to determine how big the
damage is gonna be from a climate change
and that in turn actually depends on the
level of damage to be done to existing
structures so for example we've seen a
lot of stories in the recent past
hurricanes are becoming
or financially ruinous hurricanes are
doing more damage well maybe it's not
the Hurricanes are doing more damage
maybe it's there's more stuff in the way
really like if you're building more
expensive stuff and then the hurricane
tears down more expensive stuff it turns
out it's a more expensive storm and this
is particularly true on the coast where
the Hurricanes happen you know the the
rebuilding of New Orleans is a perfectly
great example of what we should not be
doing as a society in the aftermath of a
massive natural disaster like you know
what we should do right where there was
a giant levee breach and thousands of
people died we should probably build
that city right back up again instead of
saying well you know what why are we do
what people have historically done when
their town gets washed out and you don't
not build a town there again instead we
decide to rebuild New Orleans and then
when the levees are breached again in 20
years we'll talk about climate change
again instead of recognizing that
certain eventualities are happening to
the climate and perhaps the best
mitigation factor would be to take out
the measures and maybe the best
innovation would actually be a better
way of curbing carbon emissions so as I
talked about yesterday on the program a
little bit when it comes to carbon
emissions it seems worthwhile to discuss
the fact that our carbon emissions have
dropped radically in the United States
thanks to fracking which the left hate
natural gas has taken over for coal
which the left hate now pick a solution
if you actually care about this stuff
you have to be in favor of fracking if
you care about this stuff you have to be
in favor of nuclear power instead what
the left really wants is a bunch of
redistribution of wealth and alarmism in
order to push for redistribution well
why do you think we don't trust you if
you want to base this on moderate
assessments you can fulfill then we can
discuss solutions and costs and benefits
but if you just say climate change is
happening and if you deny that we ought
to have a massive global carbon tax then
no one else will apply except the United
States then you are denier then you
don't go after yourself dude because
honestly that has no relation to reality
okay time for a couple of things that I
like and then a couple of things that I
hate so things that I like today we will
do a couple do one so there's a there's
a new movie from the Coen brothers on
Netflix I do love that Netflix is
actually now commissioning full-scale
films that are that are interesting so I
am NOT the world's biggest Coen Brothers
fan I like I like No Country for Old Men
I like Fargo but I'm not like the hugest
Coen Brothers fan by any stretch of the
imagination they have a new a new kind
of compendium film out called The Ballad
of Buster
and it's basically six short stories
that have no relation to each other
except that they all happen in the Old
West some of the stories are good some
of them are bad some of them are funny
some of them are kind of tragic all of
them are basically the Coen brothers
nihilistic Sensibility life doesn't mean
anything and then you die so that's kind
of messed up but there are some elements
of it that are really that are really
great the firt the opener The Ballad of
Buster Scruggs a lot of people don't
like it I thought it was really funny as
a parody of westerns
it's here's a little bit of the the
preview of the Ballad of Buster Scruggs
people are so easily distracted so I'm
the distractor with a little story
people can't get enough of them because
well they connect the stories to
themselves I suppose and we all love
hearing about ourselves
so long as the people in the stories are
us
[Music]
but not us this will play out a tale
so some of this is really good you know
it's frustrating because some of them
are some of these are really not great
but they're there elements of this that
are that are pretty I would say of the
of these six stories that it tells three
of them are good and three of them are
really mediocre but if you have a short
attention span it's really kind of
fantastic and it's cool that Netflix is
commissioning creative projects like
this so that's kind of neat okay time
for a couple of things that I hate thing
that I hate number one they're a bunch
of people who say that when it comes to
transgenderism and they debate about use
of pronouns and the definition of gender
and all this stuff that it has no real
world of world real world effects
yesterday I told you the story of what
happened in a local gym near me we're a
bunch of Orthodox Jewish women go
because they want gender segregation
they don't for Jewish law reasons and
for modesty reasons they don't want to
exercise it in front of men nor do they
want to see naked men or anything of the
like a transgender woman came into the
locker room refused to go into the
private area and basically threatened to
sue if they did not allow this man to
unclothed himself in front of these
Orthodox women the Orthodox woman
started dropping their memberships the
gym could do nothing about it because
they were afraid of legal liability
there are real-world consequences to
this kind of stuff and we talked
yesterday about trying to force doctors
to perform surgeries that have no actual
bearing on health or not right I mean
that which is a violation of the
Hippocratic oath well now there's
another story that is just a shocking
story from Walt hire of the Federalist
he reports about a Texas divorce case
which now pits a mother who dresses her
six-year-old male child James as a girl
and calls him Luna against James's
father whom she's accusing of child
abuse for a fusing to treat James as a
girl so the kids six years old and mom
wants James to be Luna James wants to be
James when he's with dad but weirdly
enough he wants to be Luna when he's
with mom because mom wants him to be
Luna now mom is trying to sue dad and
claim child abuse because dad won't go
along with this nonsense hey this stuff
is gonna become more and more common
there are real-world consequences to all
of these discussions it's so funny for
the left it's always like what if we
just changed this fundamental social
standard this won't hurt you in any way
we heard this about gay marriage and gay
marriage won't hurt you in any way
you're married to a woman your man
you're married to a woman how does my
gay marriage hurt you that's a well it
doesn't but it does change the social
standard of what marriage is and how we
marriage to kids and that sort of
teaching does have implications for the
behavior of children if I don't want my
kid to engage in a same-sex relationship
because I'm the parent and I think it is
more healthy to engage in a heterosexual
relationship with someone that that they
can have kids with right there because I
think that that is the ideal and now I'm
supposed to teach my kids how that has a
public policy ramification for me it has
a public policy ramification for me if
you now want me to invite a gay couple
into my synagogue violating my religious
scruples or into my religious school
violating my religious scruples right
there our public public policy
consequences to hot button social issues
pretending otherwise is just foolishness
again if you just wanted to say gay
people get married there's no imposition
on anybody else if that's a rule you
want to hold to I am all with it man do
whatever you want to do you want to go
to your church your liberal Church and
get married to remember the same sex
your problem it's a free country I don't
really care I mean count on a religious
level but on a public policy level
certainly do not care but I am NOT going
to stand by while you change full-scale
social standards and then mandate that I
teach my child some this is why I always
say when it comes to transgender folks
if I'm in a conversation with a
transgender person I'm not going out of
my way to use their biological sex when
I talk with them but if you're asking me
about public policy I'm not going to lie
and pretend that biological sex does not
exist and people take this as a lack of
sympathy for folks who are transgender
it's not a lack of sympathy for folks
for our transgender people are suffering
these people have a serious serious
disorder but it is also not helpful to
engage a country in a wide-scale
violation of biological standards in
order to supposedly quash the the
feelings hurt that people are feeling
because of the disorder you can't do
that and I love the assumption that
because I disagree with you about the
the forced the force-feeding of gender
terminology because I disagree with you
about the violation of basic freedoms
for hundreds of millions of people in
favor of a false perception of reality
of a few that because this is the case I
somehow lack sympathy for people who are
suffering it's just that there is no
evidence of that whatsoever you know I
and there is it ok so I'll tell the
story in the in the least
indicative of a so I spoke into
University rep pretty recently and in
the last few months and at this
university there was an exchange that
took place where a transgender person
came up and asked about transgenderism
and we had this exchange and the
transgender person who's a transgender
woman meeting a biological male who
believes that he is a woman in a man in
a male body and has had surgeries and
hormone trip and all the rest this
person got up and asked me about
transgenders and we had a back and forth
the exchange did not go as the
transgender person wanted and the person
became very emotional and rushed out of
the room I personally reached out
because this person was obviously
suffering I personally reached out to
this person I had the the people who
were filming the event cut that part out
of the tape because I didn't feel like
there would be anything in it for there
there's nothing good that can come from
it I don't want anybody feel humiliated
or bad when they go to my events that's
not the goal of the events we cut it out
of the tape I had coffee with the person
the next day to make sure this person
was okay isn't a lack of sympathy when
you're discussing public policy and you
mistake public policy discussions for
lack of sympathy because we disagree it
gets really ugly really quickly and it's
nasty politics at its worst okay one
more thing that I hate so as I just
mentioned briefly earlier it's really
funny how certain biases in American
society and global society get a lot of
play Islamophobia racism anti-semitism
always sort of takes a backseat because
it's old we don't want to talk about
anti-semitism like come on we've been
doing that for like thousands of years
it's boring at this point only one
problem when it comes to actual real
world bias and real world hatred and
real world stereotyping you don't need
to scratch beneath the surface very far
to find anti-semitism it's so funny
people in the u.s. talking about racing
they're like ooh dog whistles that's
where we see racism really we can't
point to specific behavior all that
often when we do everybody agrees is bad
we can't point to specific behavior all
that often and say you know that was
really racist instead it's that's a dog
whistle
that's a dog whistle you know who
doesn't dog whistle anti-semites who
come out right out and say anti-semitic
things there's a new poll from CNN
there's a sweeping new survey in Europe
more than a quarter of Europeans polled
believe Jews have too much influence in
business and finance that's not dog
whistling gang that's just anti-semitism
nearly one in four said Jews have too
much influence in conflict and wars
across the world Europe always
great to the Jews one-in-five said they
have too much influence in the media the
same number believe they have too much
influence in politics meanwhile a third
of Europeans said they knew little or
nothing about the Holocaust which
happened within the living memory of a
lot of people the mass murder of some
six million Jews in lands controlled by
the Nazi regime those are among the key
findings of this new CNN report so while
we talk about all different forms of
bias it turns out that the most durable
form of bias continues to be
anti-semitism and I love all the people
who say they're not anti-semitic but the
Jews control everything a few people
said they personally have an unfavorable
attitude toward Jews across seven
countries in the survey only one in ten
people said they did which is pretty
shocking the figure rises to 15% in
Poland and 19% in Hungary so that's 20
percent of people in Hungary saying yeah
we don't like the Jews like right out
straight up Jews suck right and we're
not gonna worry about that in every
country polls except Hungary
significantly more people said they had
a favorable opinion of Jews versus an
unfavorable opinion in Hungary favorable
to unfavorable was 29% to 19% so Hungary
if you're a Jew in Hungary you might
want to think about you know getting out
of there the poll also put a spotlight
on European attitudes toward other
minorities and it's it's it's pretty
obvious how how open this stuff is a
quarter of hung and I love this you know
one of the ways that you can tell how
people if people are an sematic like
that a kind of trick question is how
many jews do you think there are because
people who are deeply concerned about
the jews think that the jews are like a
huge percentage of the world population
it turns out that the jews are a tiny
percentage there's like 13 million Jews
worldwide which is a percentage of the
population it's nothing right as a
percentage of the population we're
talking significantly under 1% of the
population worldwide the 1/4 of
hungarians estimated the world is more
than 22 percent Jewish no they were off
by a factor of about a hundred 0.2% of
the world's population is Jewish in fact
Israel is the only country on planet
earth where more than 2 percent of the
population is Jewish so anti-semitism
continues to be the more storable hatred
and also the hatred people will ignore
as we saw yesterday when it turns out
that over the weekend there was a guy
whose name was Muhammad Muhammad who
Allahu Akbar while trying to run down to
Jews in the Hancock Park neighborhood of
Los Angeles which I know quite well
having been a Los Angeles Jewish
resident for years this got national
coverage for five seconds and then went
away because it was not a white
supremacist inspired by President Trump
alrighty well we will be back here
tomorrow to talk about all the latest
news have a great rest of the day we'll
see you here tomorrow
be here or you will miss your assigned
listening come on I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the bench Bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wha
era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
Ford publishing production copyright
Ford publishing 2018